foreign
here's what Jake has to say I've been
dating my girlfriend for three years and
she's in her first year of med school
she'll have over three hundred thousand
dollars of student loan debt by the time
she graduates I'm planning to propose to
her after I graduate and get a good
paying job a year from now I'm 24 and
I'll graduate debt free with a finance
degree later this year I've got 20 000
in savings and I'm wondering if I should
use that and the income I'll have for my
future job to help pay for her med
school since her debt will be mine once
we get married I don't like debt and 300
000 just feels overwhelming to me I
don't know if it's a good plan to pursue
and my parents don't think I should do
it since we're not married yet I was
initially planning to use my savings to
put a down payment on a house once I
graduate and get a job I would like to
get a second opinion on this we'll give
you that we might give you a third one
yeah we'll give you some opinions Jake
here's the deal
until you're and this is for everybody
until you're married we don't suggest
combining finances we don't suggest
paying for your girlfriends this paying
for your boyfriends that even if your
fiance status we don't we don't suggest
going to that level because here's the
thing you don't know if it's going to
work out and if it doesn't work out and
you've dropped you know the 20K that
you've painstakingly saved you know for
a home down payment man you're up a
creek and you're feeling you're feeling
terrible at that point now let's talk
about this 300 cane student loan debt
let's just pretend George that that
everything goes right that in a year
from now he's able to graduate he pops
the question she says yes and they get
married let's say that happens a year
from now then and only then he could
start talking they could start talking
about okay how are we gonna pay this
debt off together but until then it's
simply just a conversation they can
start plotting out they can make sure
they're on the same page moving forward
and that's probably where you need to
start Jake is having some conversations
with her because she you're you're not
okay with debt but she was okay with
taking out three hundred thousand
dollars of debt and uh you guys need to
have a conversation about that because
if she's okay with debt and you're not
then uh you guys are gonna run into some
friction ahead now I would advise this
if she hasn't already taken out the
student loans because you said she's got
a couple of years until she graduates
let's try to convince her to pay cash
and pay as she goes slow down a little
bit see if she can find some programs uh
that will help supplement her education
so that she's not having to go into the
student loan debt there is always a way
to pay for school and we have a Ramsay
personality here Christina Ellis she
specializes in that George she was able
to earn over 500 000 in scholarships and
went to amazing schools Vanderbilt man
she's way smarter than me yeah so I'm
telling you there is a way to do this I
think you need to have that conversation
but I do not I repeat I do not want you
spending your money on her education
especially now in this boyfriend
girlfriend Zone definitely not in the
fiance Zone not until you get married
what do you think George well the end of
the question was I want to use my
savings for a down payment on a house
once I graduate and get a job and the
truth is if you plan on marrying her
this could delay that dream good point
and that stinks and that's one thing
that debt does to your life it delays
your dreams and if you don't believe me
go watch borrow the future and hear the
numerous stories about how student loans
have held people back from becoming
homeowners getting married from having
kids and it's heartbreaking and so I
would suggest you two sit down and watch
that together and you can help her
develop a plan to try to graduate debt
free but don't put a dime towards it and
I would pause on this home purchase
until we know more are we gonna get
married because Lord knows she's going
to want to move somewhere else and you
didn't pick the right place yeah and the
wall color is not the right one and so I
would just put pause on this keep saving
up that down payment have the emergency
fund in place you keep living your life
debt-free and have those values
conversations around money that's right